هذا وقالت وزاره الصحه في غزه ان القصف
المتواصل على القطاع ادى الى استشهاد
158 فلسطينيا خلال ساعات ال4 الماضيه
وافاد مراسل الجزيره قبل قليل بارتفاع عدد
الشهداء جراء الغارات الاسرائيليه في خان
يونس منذ الصباح الى 19 هذا وحصلت الجزيره
على صور للحظه الغارات واللحظات الاولى
لمحاوله انقاذ الضحايا لنتابع
[موسيقى]
يا
الله هذا البيت يتبع لال صافي بيت امن في
منطقه امنه بعيد عن الاخلاء وبعيد عن
المناطق المعاديه لليهود كانوا قاعدين
الشباب هنا واخويا وجوز بنت عمتي وصاحب
البيت وكمان اثنين معهم طلعنا جوز بنت
عمتي وا واخويا لحتى الان بندور عليه مش
ملقين من تقريبا من ساعه ونص وطلعنا صاحب
البيت وكمان شاب لحتى الان في جوزتين
بندور عليهم هل هم احياء ام اموات عند
الله لا لا نعلم
ه من فوق اول باول خذها خذها اعطيها ل
اعطيها ل اعطيها لعمها اعطيها لعمها
اعطيها لعمها هيني يا عمي هيني يابا هيني
يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
ه
يابااني لازم يطلع ا لازم يطلع يلا تضغط
عليهم ارفع البش من عليهم ايو ارفع ايوه
ارجع لورا ارجع لورا را
شلا حط رجلك على
الحيطه